- Okay, ready guys, audition him.
- It's a lot of pressure here.
(laughter)
(upbeat music)
- My name is Nick Barili
and I'm traveling the country to sit down
with some of the biggest Latinx artists
in places that have meaning to them,
and help tell their stories.
We'll talk about their
journeys and careers,
and explore issues of identity, culture,
discrimination, and representation.
This is "Seen".
(upbeat music)
♪ Here into the night ooh ♪
- I'm back in LA,
driving through Bell Gardens,
on my way to Bell Gardens Intermediate
to meet Mr. Olmos
He actually played a
huge role in the movies
that affected me through my
adolescence and childhood.
"Stand and Deliver", "Mi
Familia" and "Selena"
were all movies that made
me feel proud to be Latino.
Mr. Olmos chose Bell Gardens Intermediate
as a place for us to meet,
because it's one of the
schools that his program YCP,
Youth Cinema Project,
is actually heavily involved
in integrating film studies
into public school curriculum.
So excited to talk to
the kids and Mr. Olmos
(upbeat music)
Mr. Olmos
- Hello Nick.
- Thank you for your time.
- You're welcome man.
- Do you mind if we take these off?
- I've got my booster
and all my other shots.
- Same, same.
So of all the places in LA,
this is the one you picked.
Why is this place special to you?
- This school district,
the Montebello Unified School District
has been one of the most
prolific school districts
we've had for this program.
- I wish we had this when I was going up,
because for me when I
moved to this country
not speaking English, I
became really introverted.
I was a kid at the back of
the class who didn't say much,
who was shy to open up my mouth.
So I think talking and
writing and those things are,
can be a challenge for someone who English
is a second language, we internalize it.
It questions our self-worth,
it plays into so many different layers.
- All of our students end up
with a much stronger sense of self worth
when they're done with this program.
We start in the fourth grade.
We tried to at a younger age,
but they weren't quite ready yet.
First grade, everybody loves school,
second grade, you're
starting to learn stuff,
whether you speak the language you don't,
you're still involved.
Third grade, becomes the grade
where they start to read and write,
and so if you speak
another language first,
and you're not quite up to speed.
So that wasn't the place
where we should be at that moment.
Where we needed to catch
them is in the fourth grade,
when they had now lost
their sense of balance,
and they were like feeling
less than who they are,
and we bring them into this
program, and they excel.
I can honestly tell you that,
what we've been able to
understand will make you cry.
It brings a sense of emotion
because you're standing
there looking at kids.
If you saw them just before
they got into the program,
and then you see them during the program,
you would sit there and go,
my God, these kids are so communicative.
Of course you're making a movie.
- Right, you have to, you got no choice.
- Yeah, one's a director,
one's a producer,
one's the writer, one's you
know, the camera person.
And basically you find
yourself inside of this
making a movie,
and they all have their stories.
Now we're not teaching them out of a book,
they're teaching us out of their stories.
Let's go in the classroom, I'll show you.
- I'd love to.
(upbeat music)
- All right, quite on set.
All right, so we're
wrapping up our auditions,
how does everybody feel?
- [Group] Good.
- You're good?
Okay.
So, hi Mr. Olmos how are you?
- Hey, how are you guys?
(in Spanish)
How is everybody?
Good.
It's good to see you, good to see you.
- We're working on our auditions
for our films this year.
- Really?
- Yeah, if their name is crossed off,
they've already auditioned.
- How did they do?
- You guys answer.
- [Group] Great.
- Did they do good?
I'm very proud of you guys.
Are they all in the program?
- These are our 'YCPeeps'.
- This is my good friend Nick.
He's actually doing an interview on me,
for The Academy of Motion
Pictures, Arts and Sciences.
And you're?
- Assistant director for The Heist.
- You are assistant director.
You're?
- I am the producer.
- Producer.
- I'm the director.
- Congratulations man.
- And you're?
- I am auditioning.
- Right now?
- For the role of Andres.
- Well you wanna do it?
- No pressure.
- It's a lot of pressure here.
(laughter)
- Okay, ready guys, audition him.
- This is a robbery, get down!
Jackson, hurry up, set
up the communication.
Dre, hurry up and set up
the journaling equipment.
- Can't you see doing just that?
Besides what are doing just sitting there?
- Hey don't talk back to me,
I'm you leader, respect me.
- How did you feel about that one?
- I liked it, overall great job.
- Excellent.
(soft music)
- And you're auditioning right now?
- Yes.
- Let me hear it.
- Good morning Danny.
- Fatima, you seem really
excited for class today.
- Wait, is there a free period today?
- No silly today Professor
is gonna announce
the final project of the semester.
- Oh you had to remind me.
- It's not that bad.
I've already organized my full schedule
to fit in with the assignment.
- How can you be so organized?
- I loved it, you did really good.
- I just feel you should
add a bit more movement,
when you like, oh, you had to remind me.
- That's good.
- I think this one is good.
- Have you directed before?
- No.
- It's your first time,
how do you like it?
- I really like it because I
feel like I can make the actors
like have a better performance.
Like when they come in, they're good,
but I kind of wants to
give them like adjustments
on how they could be way
better and on top of it
and really good.
(soft music)
- I just wanna thank all of you very much
for everything you guys are doing.
You guys are truly the future,
and whether you become filmmakers
or you don't become filmmakers,
that's not the issue,
the issue is that you've
gotten the opportunity
to understand yourselves, your stories,
and that you learned
self-esteem ,self-respect
and self-worth.
Congratulations all of
you, I'm very proud of you.
- All right, here we
go, a round of applause.
(clapping)
- We'll have to continue
with the conversation,
let's sit down.
- Perfect.
(soft music)
- Wow, those kids being
able to recite lines
in front of cameras,
that was pretty amazing.
(laughs)
How does it feel to see the
generation start that young
into the craft that you've
mastered all these decades?
- This is a dream.
You don't quite get it
until you really
experience the differences,
and these kids have become whole.
They're able to look at
you and to talk with you.
They have confidence,
self-esteem, self-respect,
and they've only been doing
it for like six months.
- I always like to start interviews,
kind of like the intro
sequence of a movie.
Like when that pan shot comes
into your childhood home,
what are we seeing?
What are we hearing?
What are we smelling?
- Well, I come from the Ellis
Island of the West Coast,
that's what it's called.
So my background came from being,
just a kid in East LA, playing in the,
there was no grass or anything,
it was just dirt lots and.
It was beautiful, there was a lot of love,
but it was not any kind of
fluent living whatsoever.
- How did growing up in East LA shape you?
- Well, it gave me a sense
of balance of who I was
because we were, you know,
multitude of cultures.
So we had indigenous people
living right to my right hand,
as I come out my front door,
there was a house with Apache Indians.
To the left, there was a
family of the Martinez,
they were a Mexican American.
Right across the street,
we had Japanese family.
They all had kids and all
of us played together.
And what happened by coming from there,
I was exposed to the clarity of culture.
And I didn't know anything
about any kind of cultural differences,
discrimination or any kind
of prejudice systems at all.
So we were exposed to religions,
we're exposed to cultures,
and I thought that that's
how the whole world was.
Until I left, I crossed the LA river,
or the first street bridge,
and I first saw that
there was still Africans,
but they were in one corner,
Indigenous people were not
even, you couldn't find them.
And then the Asian community
was stuck in another corner,
the Latino community was in
Pacoima and in the valley,
and the Caucasian community
was on the west side,
and it was quite interesting.
- Your first love was actually baseball.
You were a catcher, you
caught Sandy Koufax.
We shared something,
my knees still hurt from
when I used to catch.
- Eddie Roebuck was the guy
that I really worked with
the most that during that period
of time, Sandy pitched too.
But we were playing the
California Sun League,
and I played every day, seven days a week.
I learned the whole understanding of
you had to spend 10,000 hours.
- To master.
- You would just be all that you could be.
It didn't make you
better than anybody else,
it just made you whole.
That discipline to do
the things you love to do
when you don't feel like
doing them, came to light.
And that was four or five years old
when I stumbled on to this.
And so by the time I was 12, 11, 12,
I was playing really
strongly and I was catching.
And like you, you know, my knees, oh boy.
We used to do double headers
and sometimes triple headers.
So I was playing 21 innings a day,
it was single A ball getting
ready to go into double AA
and triple AAA and getting
picked up by the majors.
- That's part of the Dodger system right?
- Yes, that was one of them.
- So you're on your way
to become a professional
baseball player, right?
You're you're in the Dodger system,
you're 13, you get your
discipline for baseball.
Then you're like,
at some point you're like,
I wanna be in a rock band.
What was that moment like,
and how did you parents feel about that?
- That moment destroyed my father.
I'll never forget it.
He didn't quite get it,
but how could he have gotten it?
Everybody in the world told him,
you know, this he's a
really natural, natural.
Natural is just years and
year and years of hard work,
make you a natural.
There was nothing natural
about me playing baseball.
about me being a rock and roll singer,
there was nothing natural
about me being an actor.
- What drew to rock and roll?
What was it about rock
and roll that caught you?
- It was the rhythm,
the intense rhythms and the feeling
that you got listening to it.
My father, who was a very good
dancer and my mother was too,
but he was for me a great,
great asset of understanding
because he was a,
he could move.
And so we would clean the house and stuff,
he'd put on Perez Prado,
or he'd put on Tito Puente,
he'd put on all the great
Latin music that there was.
And while he was cleaning,
we were cleaning and stuff,
he would move.
And so we would see him moving
and we'd start to move with
him, dying of laughter,
because when you're a little kid
and you're doing all these
things you never did before,
but you're moving to the music.
So he got me into music
and that's what happens.
You get exposed to certain things,
it changes your perspective on life.
So at 1960, I was playing
baseball every day,
seven days a week.
But then I realized that, you know what,
I wanna sing and dance.
I love baseball,
but I really love singing
and dancing and moving.
And so I went into that,
the same way I played baseball,
I hung up my cleats, 14 years old,
I hung up my cleats and my father lost it.
And it was sad because
he really got hurt by it.
I didn't know how much,
because I was so stuck on my own world.
I'm gonna go sing and dance,
you know, what the heck's wrong with you?
But then he realized that
I started doing the music
like I had done baseball,
and pretty soon I was performing.
Couldn't sing very well,
but man, could I perform.
I could move and dance using
my Latin and my African roots.
I would perform seven days a week.
So we were constantly working.
And then one day I went
to audition for a play.
They asked for two Latino actors to go up
to the main stages of Los Angeles,
which has Mark Taper,
and wow, they sent me as one of the guys.
And so I went and I didn't get the part,
but as I was walking
out, I heard a, hey you.
And I turned around,
and a miscellaneous girl, young girl,
and she goes, "Yeah you, you yeah, yeah.
I'm talking to you.
Do you want to try out for
a play that we're doing?"
I said, "What play?"
She goes, "Do you or don't you?"
I go, "Yes I do, yes I do."
I could see that she was like questioning
why she even stopped me.
And so she goes, I go,
"Yes I would thank you."
She goes, "Okay be here on
a Monday at three o'clock."
So I left, came back on
Monday at three o'clock,
it was hundreds of guys there.
And there was this play called "Zoot Suit"
so I got to do that.
That was a combination of
using theater, movement,
singing, all of the things
that I had been doing
day in and day out for years.
'Cause I've been doing theater since 1964,
I got in my first acting class
in East LA Community College.
- Can you speak a little bit about
what went into that character.
What were all the elements
that came into you crafting Pachuco?
- Everything that I have
been working towards
and understanding through my
life, were funneled into this,
I could use it in this performance.
This character became
capable of using it all,
I mean, it was amazing what happened
with that character. El Pachuco,
to this day, is still profoundly
one of the most beloved characters
to rise on the American stage
in the history of American theater.
Not me saying that,
that was the American Theater who said it.
And I mean, it was the character,
granted I was capable of
handling the responsibility,
which was, thank the Lord I was ready
because we really needed it.
The year was 1978 and
there had never been a play
dealing with the Latino culture
other than "West Side Story".
But studying the Puerto
Rican in "West Side Story",
was like studying the
Polynesian in "South Pacific".
It wasn't meant to study the culture,
it was meant to use the
culture to tell a story,
which was fine.
This was the first time the
culture had ever spoken.
This was a culture that spoke,
and what it said was monumental.
That play changed the perspectives
and the understandings
of the Latino culture
in this country and opened it up.
- How did it feel for a
group of kids in East LA,
not only do you put on for the city,
but then go to Broadway and send ripples
throughout the world.
I mean, I read that people were coming in
from like London Theater
and Moscow Theater,
and all these different places,
just to see what you guys were doing.
- Yeah, they did.
And they came when we were here in LA.
And what the shot, was
heard around the world,
that's how strong the piece was.
I have to give it to Louis
and to Gordon Davidson,
those two giants of the American theater,
where the people who really created this,
and allowed it to be born.
- I read that you did 13 years of theater
without getting a paycheck, is that true?
- Yeah, yeah.
- All right, can you speak on that,
'cause I feel like people
hear that and they're like,
you have to really love something
to do for 13 years for nothing.
- For nothing.
I played baseball for nothing.
- I mean you're in this rock band,
you're not getting paid,
you're doing theater,
you're not getting paid.
Like you probably have other
jobs that are paying the bills,
while you're doing all this.
- I used to deliver furniture.
(laughs)
- You delivered furniture?
- Yeah, yeah, I mean that's
how I supported myself
for a long time too.
I had a van from playing
in rock and roll music,
you know, between the
situations of working on stage,
I would deliver like two
o'clock in the morning,
three o'clock in the morning,
I'd be delivering furniture from auctions.
- Wow.
So you're performing
and then a two o'clock
you're going to deliver furniture.
- Yeah, from two to seven.
- That's dedication.
I feel like one of the
most empowering things
of your career,
is that you found a way to make
all the characters you played your own.
How are you able to accomplish that?
- Since El Pachuco, I've
had creative control
of my characters.
And no one argues, no one says,
you know, Eddie, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no.
I could have never worked
with Alfred Hitchcock,
he didn't need anybody
else to add to his movies.
Okay, I get it, that's perfect, go for it.
Just don't call me,
because I might think of something
that might enhance your story.
And that's all I do, I mean,
there's some times when
I never changed a dot,
a period, nothing.
I do exactly what's on the page
because it's perfectly done.
And then sometimes I'll augment it
and move it to another level
and they're very grateful.
- Take me to the "Stand and Deliver".
Tell me a little bit about
how that came to be made,
'cause I heard that it took
five years for that to happen.
- Yeah.
- You guys filmed it
independently, is that correct?
- Yes, yes we did.
- Anyone who sees it, it's
such a powerful story,
but when you pitched it to Hollywood,
what were they telling you in terms of why
they couldn't finance it?
- Well, basically the one
line that really just like,
hit us like a ton of bricks.
So we would go like the NBC or CBS,
then suddenly NBC said,
you know, the day that
you wanna do this story,
which is a wonderful
story, don't get me wrong.
And they say, well, you know,
they'll play "Terminator"
on the same night
that were playing "Stand and Deliver",
what do you think people are gonna watch?
And I said, "Stand and
Deliver" it's a better story.
And then they chuckled and
they let us leave the room.
No we got our money funding
from the Public Broadcasting, PBS,
and the American Playhouse,
which started the seed money.
It costs us about a million
two to do the movie.
- Wow.
- So we got 10,000 from this person,
15,000 from this person,
200,000 from this person.
You know, different people
would give us to make up
for the 1.2 million that we
needed to make the movie.
We had captured lightning in a bottle.
And I'm very grateful
because that movie has helped
so many people.
- I saw it recently and
it definitely stands
the test of time.
What do you think it is about the movie
that can resonate from
generation to generation?
- I think it's the story.
The story itself,
the truth of the story itself is powerful.
A hundred years from today,
that movie will be seen and
understood and be appreciated.
All we wanted to do is just document
the behavior of this man.
And we did it,
and I was very fortunate
I was able to do it.
- [Narrator] Edward James Olmos
for a "Stand and Deliver".
- We did not have Spanish surnames
and come from Barrio school you know that.
There's something going on here
that nobody's talking about,
and you know what it is.
I know well how to spell discrimination.
I thought this was over a long time ago.
Are you doing this to my kids?
My kids could teach you
a thing or two Johnny.
- I'm gonna call security
if you can't control yourself Escalante.
- Go for it.
(clapping)
- That movie received a nomination
for a best leading actor.
You are the only US born
Latino to be nominated
for best actor or best actress.
- In the history of the Academy.
Why do you think it's been such a struggle
to get another US born
Latino to that stage
where they could be nominated.
Latino or Latina, because
that applies to both.
- Either, it's just a story.
The roles are what define it.
And it's been very hard
to get that opportunity.
Like for instance,
"Argo" a beautiful movie,
best movie of the year when it came out.
Got all kinds of accolades for
Ben Affleck and everything,
but it didn't win him the Academy Award.
Had he used a Latino.
- Which is what the story was about.
- Yeah, it was about a Mexican American,
but nobody ever knew it.
Tony Mendez was the character
that they portrayed,
but they used his name a couple of times,
but it's so thrown away that most people,
you could ask them,
did you know that this was
a Mexican American person?
It was the Mexican American culture.
No, no.
- You've been a strong
advocate for representation
for a long time, why is
that important for you?
- To me, trying to understand your life
and then your culture, and your heritage,
and the roots that make
you the tree that you are,
and the human being that you are,
sharing it so that
others can understand it,
makes everybody stronger.
And that's why I'm a storyteller,
and that's why I got into this,
and that's why I stand
here today telling stories,
and trying desperately hard to listen.
Listening is the key.
I listened to you Nick,
you're very, very educated
in respects of knowing
who and what I am.
And I'm very proud of the fact
that I'm being interviewed
by someone who really
understands who I am,
and it makes a big difference.
And I appreciate you doing
the work that you've done
to understand what
you're doing here today.
- You don't know how seen
I feel at this moment.
I feel like it's been 25
years to get on the seat,
just like you said,
the 13 years of theater that
no one paid you or whatever,
it's like it all comes
to this place right now.
- Yes it does.
- Throughout your career,
you've not only acted,
you've directed, you've
written stuff, you've produced,
why is it important for
you to wear multiple hats?
- Out of a necessity to
stay alive in this industry,
I had to learn the full
usage of storytelling.
Whether it be in songwriting,
filmmaking, or theater.
If we weren't creating it,
we weren't gonna be able to do it,
because nobody was creating it for us.
- Seen what you've seen,
and experienced what you've experienced,
what will you tell a young
actor, director, writer,
Latino, Latina who's watching this,
who maybe hasn't seen as much
of themselves represented
when they turn on the
streamers or go to the movies,
but who wants to do it,
what advice would you have for them?
- The strongest advice
I can give any artists
in any perspective,
disciplines, is don't stop.
Don't let anything stop you, die doing it.
You know, just don't stop.
You know, success is not money,
it's not fame, it's not fortune,
success is having lived your life
doing what you really want it to do,
and doing it to the best of your ability.
That means you spend thousands of hours
doing it in this lifetime.
Just don't stop,
don't let anything stop you.
The key is to do the things you wanna do
when you don't feel like doing them.
So the moment you wanna stop
and say, this is too much,
I can't take the rejection or,
you know, no one really
cares about my music,
nobody cares about my movies,
nobody cares about me,
nobody cares about anything.
Ah, I don't care about me,
I don't care about myself, I'm stopping,
that never can you do.
You must never stop.
- You've had iconic roles,
you help found LALIFF, Youth Cinema,
Latino Public Broadcast.
We can go on and on and on and on,
what's left to accomplish for you?
- When I pass and leave this world,
I could have done way more work,
'cause I would've been
offered a lot of work,
more work I've been
offered than I've taken.
People say, why did he do that?
You could have been a lot
more famous and a lot richer.
(laughs)
I said, yeah, but in essence,
I wouldn't have felt the way
I feel right this moment.
I have movies that I'd like to make,
that I've been trying
to make for 35 years,
that I still haven't been able to make.
And I hope that I can make them,
and if I don't, I'm gonna die trying,
and all I can tell you.
- Thank you for your time.
Thank you for all the
doors that you've opened
and knocked down for generations to come.
Thank you for full circle moment,
we're we're here in the classroom,
"Stand and Deliver" was so impactful,
and now we're actually
in a classroom with kids
and impacting a whole new generation.
Thank you for all that you do.
My honor, my privilege,
thank you for your
kindness and your respect.
(soft music)
- It's hard to even put what
just happened in the words.
I feel all this like rush
of energy coming through me.
I just feel gratitude from Mr. Olmos
for sharing his time,
and the moment where he just
acknowledged the research
and just the work.
You know, being in this
industry for 25 years,
you don't really have a
lot of moments like that,
where you actually feel like
what I'm doing is being
seen by this person
that I look up to and have
admired my whole life.
So can't even know what the
next episode is gonna be
and how we're gonna be
able to top this one.
We're gonna find a way to
bring this level of energy
to every episode that we do.
(upbeat music)